so I've got Ryan back but it's not gonna
be as good as the last time so yes in
the New Year Ryan back for the first
time and the reason for that intro is
the topic of today which we're going to
talk about some of the worst movies
equal oh you were being topical yeah
you're just being a jerk
well III can do both and also I do I'll
just note this and maybe it won't matter
but this won't be the first video that
goes out using my new camera but it is
the first one I'm recording with it so
if this looks like high-def garbage
that's why and I apologize I'm only
holding up two fingers yeah okay so Ryan
first of all happy new year welcome back
thank you happy new year to you happy
new year to all of your like 10 million
followers that you've gotten else oh I
wish but so yeah um when I when I told
you that you know let's talk about some
of the worst movie sequels one of the
things I didn't do was set out a
criteria because I have mine and I kind
of wanted to leave you to come up with
your own so what was the criteria you
had for for the ones you want to bring
up um so it was a good quick like as
soon as you sent like worst sequels I
was like okay well the ones that
everybody's going to talk about
Godfather - Wrath of Khan the ones that
everybody hates okay I'm gonna let
people have heart attacks for a hot
second no the first one I cuz i kind of
instantly went to i was like okay we do
need some criteria here because like and
my money instantly went to some of the
horror franchises was like there's like
20 different Friday the 13th movies or I
mean I was like I first wanted I've seen
some of these are just bad like where's
the cutoff so for my criteria I kind of
went with a few different things I went
with sequels that probably just should
not have been because of one reason
the story didn't lend itself to a sequel
or too much time had passed and it's
like the relevance of this movie is just
not there anymore
also if the movie was particularly bad
that helped although there are some
movies that I did bring that I would
argue are not bad movies but might meet
a certain criteria for a bad sequel okay
that'll be in some of the other
criterias that I came up with which I'll
talk a lot about our movies that kind of
betray or negate something that was
special and important and likable about
the preceding movie so movie they're
kind of like hey and we really like this
one we're gonna make a sequel and the
storyline either by necessity or
accident kind of gives the middle finger
to what you just saw almost as if the
previous movie storyline didn't
accomplish anything or wasn't didn't
matter okay and sometimes I think those
are more of like the worst offenders and
if I come up with another idea I'm a fly
I'll probably regret it but those were
basically I wasn't just thinking I
wasn't just thinking of like purely bad
movies because what I could talk about
like Greece - I had two major criteria
basically these these were exclusionary
criteria okay so things that fell under
these Kevin this was how I thinned the
herd cuz I write you look at bad sequels
it's a lot but automatically excluded
anything that was direct-to-video yeah
that was off the table the next thing
was that for me it had to be a major
drop-off from the quality of the
immediately preceding film which gets me
out of most of say your your
long-running horror franchises cuz most
of them don't drop off and like jaws 4
is bad
but it's only a little bit worse than
jaws 3 which is only a little bit worse
than jaws 2 the biggest drop off is from
Jaws 1 - jaws - so if you're gonna argue
any of the by my criteria as the bad
sequel is supposed to because it's the
biggest drop from the one that came
immediately before it and there yeah and
I actually I probably had that in mind
too which is why I didn't include
weekend at Bernie's -
[Laughter]
so that that was my major criteria I've
got how many did I write down I think I
came up one two three I've got 13 here
that are I feel a double what I drew
touching on okay
well three of these I would lump
together for all not actually four of
these I would lump together for all
committing the exact same sin okay so
okay I'll save those so you know what
let's actually start with one that you
mentioned but I think is worth bringing
up Blues Brothers 2000 because you want
to talk about not all not only a movie
that didn't need a sequel whose time had
passed
yeah and has a serious drop off from the
previous film now I'm actually I'm even
a little bit of a Blues Brothers 2000
apologist insofar as I do think the
musical numbers are actually really good
nothing else about it is good and the
musical numbers honestly at least for me
weren't even the biggest highlight into
the original film anyway they were great
but it was those two characters together
and guess what you don't have in the
sequel because one of them is dead
uh-huh yeah no I had I even given it
some consideration I would have had on
the list for the exact same reason
piggyback on that because the first
movie that I kind of thought of because
of the time really had passed is and
this is probably the objectively the
worst movie of the ones that I came up
with was Basic Instinct - oh here's a
quote have you seen it yeah oh my god I
made the effort to see it I rented it I
paid money for how this is going to
happen to me let's see it and it was I
think that's no way to frame this is
watching that movie is just something
that happens to you right and it's like
getting hit by a bus right and until I
watched like the first 45 minutes of
what's the gray one 50 shades of grey I
did watch like 45 minutes of it I've
actually seen all of that post
okay until that movie Basic Instinct to
have the record of the movie that I was
most bored
watching people try to be sexy oh yeah
and now so getting back into it because
I do think there's a nose because I want
the first Basic Instinct I got it okay
it has them I wasn't gonna ask like how
I I'm I'm willing to accept that Basic
Instinct 2 is significantly below but
how high are we actually placing the
first base against it okay the first
Basic Instinct has a reputation Sharon
Stone showing something to the audience
which the the legend scene and
everything she's naked for half a movie
it's just a it's you could call it a
softcore / yeah it's I would call it a
medium core if you take all of that out
of it
it's actually still a really engrossing
murder mystery and it's a good thriller
and I think it I think it actually it
holds up now that could be me maybe big
project that I like the first Basic
Instinct now but you're certainly going
to watch that movie for one particular
reason and the reason was Sharon Stone
even in the first Basic Instinct I think
was in her mid 30s yeah
the sequel comes out 15 years later I
think she's pushing 50 and I don't want
to be ageist and I think you can
certainly be sexy but the reason you go
to see a movie like that probably isn't
to see a woman no matter how beautiful
and sexy she can be of that age who
looks like it now okay let me try and
save you from yourself let me ask you
this was were they trying to have the
character be sexy in the sequel in the
same way she was sexy in the first one a
little bit because my and my I think the
way maybe we pull you out of this hole
you've dug yourself into is by is by
pointing out that you can be sexy in
your 50s but it is a different type of
thing someone in their 50s trying to be
sexy in a way that someone in their 30s
can get away with is kind of painful and
I think they're trying to do both I
think they're trying to be a little bit
of the sexy like and failing now the
other thing is it's just it's a bad and
it's a
but I think probably the biggest kernel
sin of this movie is and this is
something that I will get to with some
of my other movies is one of the things
that I really enjoyed about the first
one one of the great things about is the
ambiguous ending and it is something
like where if you create a sequel with
an ending to the first ones no longer
ambiguous you've created a definite a
definitive like end note for that and
thereby spoiling part of it and ruining
at least for some of the audience like
what was special about the first one so
I think it was it was a sequel that a
should not have been made because Basic
Instinct should not have had a sequel
like yeah the ambiguity of that ending
makes it special if you if you extend
the chat in the next chapter you ruined
that be if they were going to make a
sequel the time to do that was ten years
earlier than they did yeah and be he was
just like I don't even remember who her
co-star was some British guy but he was
wooden and just like yeah horrible like
performances she seemed bored by I don't
think she wanted to do I don't know I'm
sure was cashing the check and proven
it's still good yeah but now so since
you sort of gemstone if you're watching
this I still love you since you brought
up the general idea of movies that
shouldn't have sequels I think the
elephant in the room in that category is
actually one that I don't have on my
list
but I think most people's minds jump to
Highlander - mm-hmm well I yes what was
that on yours well I I thought about I
didn't even include it because I thought
you might be good well no I did here's
why though not that it's good because
it's not but here's why I find
Highlander - oddly endearing because one
thing it is not is lazy they try they
try I don't know what they were trying
to do but whatever it was they tried
hard you can see the effort up on the
screen and of all the sins of that movie
and they are legion mm-hmm it is not a
lazy cash-grab sequel it's insane and it
ruins the mythology of the first one no
matter which version you see mm-hmm but
to me the biggest car
Wilson of most sequels and again I've
got four of them together that all that
all commit this to some degree it's
being lazy
yeah relying on the same stuff yes that
to me is the biggest sin any sequel can
commit and I don't think Highlander two
does that that does not matter doing the
original sentence oh yo yes it invented
its own sins
oh sure that thing really is a bizarre
monstrosity
alright here was one that I had because
this this represented something that I
don't think happens all that often but
boy did it not work and that's a like a
complete shift in genre okay The
Chronicles of Riddick
okay I have not heard seen this one I
saw yours was the first one pitch
blocked first one was I saw the first
one
I thought it's fine I like pitch black a
lot but pitch black is a lean and mean
you know sci-fi horror story it's an
alien yeah but it's it's very it's very
tight it's very basic it is playing on
very basic fears of the dark of
isolation and then for the sequel they
basically tried to do Conan the
Barbarian and space and not only does it
bear almost no resemblance to the
previous movie and even Riddick himself
as a character barely resembles the
character II was in the previous movie
but the tone is and like it really
literally feels like they plucked to
this guy out of this one genre and
franchise and dropped him into a
completely different one and it's so
weird and also not good and I can't have
I can't add anything to having not seen
it although it certainly sounds but I
understand your point but just because
you mentioned it I would just thought of
Kony and the destroyer as a sequel to
code and the barbary see I never saw a
coming under the story cuz I know it by
reputation I've seen Conan the Barbarian
right which is very early 80's but it's
quite good and what it is and I think
Conan the Destroyer I just didn't work
which I tried to make as D&D about
it's PG first yeah yeah yeah he tried to
tone it down and hamstring a lot of what
made Arnold fun to watch in the first
one but yeah okay for my next one
actually going back to something that I
did mentioned with basic in Singh too
which was a movie but again just came
out too late it felt like a cash grab by
the people involved and yeah well III
think that the actor knew much no way
like against ami a just but this time
I'm flipping it because the the gender I
just don't think the actor was
physically up for the demands of the
role was Indiana Jones and the Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull that yeah that one
was on my list because even though again
I'm a little bit of an apologist for
that movie and that again not because I
like it but just because I don't hate it
to the degree a lot of people hate it
but yeah certainly if you're gonna
compare to Last Crusade that's a big
drop off and act although I will say
that if Crystal Skull didn't exist
Temple of Doom might have gotten a look
in on my list cuz I do not really like
Temple of Doom and I and in my mind
Raiders of the Lost Ark is
unquestionably the best Indiana Jones
most sure I do actually consider right
now Temple Doom is not as bad as Crystal
Skull but I do I do look at that gulf
okay between Raiders of the Lost Ark and
Temple of Doom and that for me at least
is a big gap so I don't I don't like the
tonal shift in Temple of Doom and how
dark it goes but I like a lot of the
other actually the darkness of Temple of
Doom isn't the thing that bothers me the
most it's how it's how they just like
throw all the insects in the gore and
like stuff that she like kind of like
it's played more for Laughs and kind of
like the gross-out factor without having
necessarily the story component yeah but
okay
so beginning in my theme for Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull was in addition to
just kind of not really liking the story
or the direction where they were going i
five minutes into this movie I was
dreadfully concerned and it was because
of Harrison Ford and I remember thinking
like he would give interviews like back
in the 90s and stuff like that and like
people were always saying like if they
ever met another star
would you go back to playing han Solo
and he was always correct I don't think
so
is that I think I did everything there
was we had character kind of bores me
not really interested and they would ask
would you ever go back to being Indiana
Jones and he said I quote in a New York
minute like he would go back like that
yeah you love that character you want to
play that game I was like them - now
we're talking about the span of time was
there okay he's an older man he's not
gonna be able to do some of the physical
things but like his first scene when
they pull him out of the trunk of the
car and he's talking to not the Nazis
anymore but the Soviets and I was just
like he seems bored out of his mind
and then this is a project you have been
waiting for for a decade to return to
this character this is a bad sign cuz I
just thought he just he wasn't into the
character I don't know what it was he
just seemed like he didn't care and it
was just bad and then like yeah there's
there's a I've seen later in the movie
where he's he's fighting this Soviet
soldier by this like hill of like fire
ants and in every movie Indiana Jones
gets his butt kicked
that's like partly he's always getting
beat up until the last minute he fights
back or something saves him or something
but like this time it was painful to
watch because it's like you're just
beating up an old man that's this isn't
what character building you're like cool
this is like oh god stop stop he's
already dead see I I actually I give
more credit for his performance in that
movie than you do but I will absolutely
grant you that fight scene was not fun
because it was like you're beating up a
senior citizen what are you doing they
are still play or make your fifth one I
know I know as much as I don't want them
to reboot it just come up with an
original three I think I would prefer a
reboot to one with him in it passing the
torch to somebody else because I also
think part of what makes this special is
the time period it is and that was also
one of the problem at least for me when
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull it didn't
matter as much once they were in the
jungle right at that first stretch when
he's like he's he goes into a diner and
there's a jukebox and people and girls
and poodle skirts I'm like no I have
expected to see Marty McFly not see that
that that would have been one to pull
for wet god like a year two years ago
when we get our movie mashups yeah
so like I also had the x-men franchise
on my list okay
twice apocalypse and x3 yes okay so yeah
xmls stem and apocalypse now I know for
you at least by the criteria I said oh
you might not include apocalypse because
you didn't like Days of Future past yes
but I did think that apocalypse was
noticeably worse oh my god I see I like
Days of Future past a lot yeah but and
and what was really great like I
probably hate apocalypse more than x-men
The Last Stand because extra blast and
which is again not good I at least know
why that happens
the creative team that was supposed to
make it left junk ship to do something
else
Fox wouldn't move the date now that's
Fox being jerks but because they
wouldn't move the date that means that
the actors the screenwriter the director
who got saddled with the thing had very
little time and limited resources and so
like the production was hamstrung
apocalypse what is your freakin excuse
for this it's the same creative team yes
set it up at the end of the last one so
obviously it was your intention to do
this they didn't force you to do this
you said how you wanted this to be the
next one you did and you don't seem to
understand any of the components that
anyone likes about this character and
it's a character I don't even like
anyway but I still recognize that they
failed to bring what people liked about
him about it's like what that's the
thing I don't understand why apocalypses
as bad as it is I understand why would
last and I think part of it with
apocalypse was just like this after you
do Days of Future past
what stakes can you set up that feel big
enough to justify like it's another end
of the world situation everything like
so yeah I will say I don't think Days of
Future past was a bad movie my problems
are very subjective and personal bias
against like certain things about the
franchise and the handling of it like
I'm never gonna tell somebody it's a bad
movie it's just I didn't like it for
various reasons that have as much to do
with me as it does with the apocalypse
like I was checking my watch just like
this is or I don't even know if it's bad
I'm not
I was so bored it was it was
aggressively media yeah oh um as for the
third one yeah I just thought yeah no I
think the thing is I can look at like I
can look at little things about the
third one and still pick out a couple of
things like I can go I let kelsey
Grammer's beast know quite a bit and
there are little moments there are a few
things some of Magneto's scenes are
pretty cool like the few things that are
good that are quote unquote good in
Apocalypse is all stuff that was H from
earlier films oh look at magneto
suffered this loss yet he's done that
like three times already
look at the Quicksilver seat you did it
already I'm living on the third one that
I really felt was clever and I'd like
the use of it was the little bit with
the multiple man and now that threw off
like the whole like the ambush that they
were setting up for the Union here's
this whole team of the world it's just
yeah I like that part I thought I was
but yeah that's obviously didn't save
the movie alright so since we're on that
this takes me to another one of the
movies which is in the superhero genre
superhero field and this one kind of
hurt me to put it on the list cuz it's
very near and dear to my heart it's also
the probably the most recent movie that
we we can look at and it's not a movie
that I would say is bad but it lets me
down in a couple of ways and it's this
past year's ant-man in the wasp
see I'm both with you and not because I
don't think it's very good but I also
didn't like ant-man nearly as much as
everyone else seemed to either right so
I like a man and I think it is worse
though oh absolutely great I like to in
man and at the time when I first saw him
and the wasp was like yeah that was fun
I kind of like that and then the more i
sat with it the more like it it kept
going lower and lower on my list of the
Marvel movies something else
bottom-5 part of the problem is like I
can't like Paul Rudd is great with this
character and he's very charming is very
funny he does a lot of like interesting
things interacting with the cast and the
girl who plays his daughter and
everything but that doesn't disguise the
very obvious
but there's no need for him to be in
this movie no and like when you look at
what is set up by the previous one like
the story Colonel is going to get Jana
out of the quantum realm but that plot
doesn't require Scott and Scott's
involvement at all no that's a hank and
hope plot and it's also something that
can be done in 15 minutes it's like one
of these things it's like it's sort of
like Harold and Kumar Go to White Castle
yeah you need to keep throwing outside
things there's this one goal that should
not be that hard and we're just gonna
keep throwing in same problem right but
the problem is within one of these is
all of these obstacles are just external
things that have nothing to do with like
characters or they're really like their
actions or responsabilities so it´s not
character it's just stuff to like thrown
it's like just like hurdles for the sake
of hurdles see that was they I remember
after Liz and I saw together when we did
a review on it we were talking about it
and I and I think I realized as we were
talking like the entire subplot would
like the yeah I forget who that a hell
he was but Walter Goggin the gangster
care yeah character and all those guys
it actually occurred to me like oh I
know why they're in here
it was reverse engineered from what
action scenes they wanted to do right
but the quote-unquote main villain they
had a ghost isn't gonna have henchmen so
they had to insert a whole other villain
who would I have henchmen so they could
have things like the chase scene and
then in the fight in the kitchen and all
this other crap well yeah the story is
not driving the set pieces the set
pieces are driving the story exactly
exactly and that's why that's why I
think there's a lot of fun in the movie
I will rewatch it from time to time if I
need to I like I'd like a lot of certain
elements of the movie but is just like
it's a sequel because they wanted to
make a sequel and they just you know I
think it was reverse engineered like
what do we want to do what can we do to
show off these powers and get people
excited yeah and then like Rebecca's
like the story is just so flimsy and
ultimately is like why is ant-man in
ant-man in the wasp or because it's a
sequel to ain't man yeah and that's the
only reason and it's just it breaks my
heart cuz I like that character and I
wanna be a bigger fan of that franchise
but
uh-huh no it fails all right I've got
one on here that I've actually never
seen but I'll mention just cuz it shows
up on so many worse lists and I'll just
acknowledge it here to say that I have
nothing to say about in that son of the
mask
I never say me neither but supposedly
like like seizure-inducing bad well okay
so though since since you brought up
superheroes I'm what about first I did
but since we've continued on with
superheroes a little bit spider-man 3
wow I didn't even think about any of the
spider-man movies but yeah I mean that
see that's the only one I would include
though because I don't consider amazing
spider-man 2 to be that big a drop off
from the previous amazing spider-man and
I'm not gonna judge reboot versus
totally other cop newest sure like or
worse two reboots that's a totally
different conversation at least to me it
is though in terms of direct sequels yes
spider-man I mean spider-man 2 which is
great just spider-man 3 which is that
right and I think a lot of that is is
Sony interfering with what Sam Raimi
wanted to do although that doesn't
excuse him because there certainly see
the thing is I don't let Sam Raimi off
no I don't I don't what and some people
like to go it's because Sony forced him
venema I will immediately grant that
didn't help but I actually think Venom's
plot was not representative of what the
comics fans like a venom I actually
think the venomous plotline is a heck of
a lot better than Sandman's probably I
actually like the visuals of salmon
which is why I like the visual but I
actually hate Sandman a hell of a lot
more than I hate venom I don't like the
way that this characters played out I
hate the ways crowbarred into the plot
and this whole wreck crowning of Uncle
Ben's death I hate and that's completely
on Raimi that was the movie he wanted to
me yeah exactly yeah I remember like
hating it when I saw and at some point
it occurred to me like every character
in this movie has a crying scene even
Harry Osborn's Butler has a crime scene
at the end of the movie
what the heck is going on with this
movie The Sandman is defeated by being
brought to tears and blowing away on the
wind I would if if we're including that
though I would include amazing
spider-man 2 because I think it is
significantly worse than the amazing
spider-man 1
I don't think amazing spider-man 1 is
great but I think there is enough of a
disparity and like the sins that amazing
spider-man 2 can like creates of just
like not being like a story but just
like silly as ice I feel but amazing
spider-man 2 has has significantly
different sins from amazing spider-man 1
but I do honestly there are components
in amazing spider-man 2 that I actually
really like they don't pull together but
I honestly really like the scene in Time
Square one electro true basically I'd
like that scene a lot I actually I mean
the build-up to it means the payoff
didn't work but I actually think Gwen
Stacy's dead as a scene as a moment was
really well handled
I honestly and I might be the only
person on the planet I honestly liked
the ending okay like leading into
leaning into the Rhino fight but more
importantly spider-man yo this kid I'm
standing out from the Ryan you know and
spider-man go hey I got it it's good I
legitimately like that ending now almost
everything that goes in between those
two things that I like doesn't work but
I can look at Amazing Spider might want
to go it's more cohesive I don't think
his high points are as high as the high
points of strider have amazing
spider-man 2 though there's nothing
there's no individual thing in the in
the first amazing spider-man that I like
as much as the individual things that I
like an amazing spider-man 2 okay um
since you said that you're probably the
only person in the world who who like
that anymore I would throw myself out
there and say I might be the only person
the world who actually liked the amazing
spider-man 2 goblin more than the Green
Goblin in the first spider-man movie
I don't like more than Willem Dafoe as
Norman Osborn but as the Goblin that
Power Rangers look in suit that he wore
I could never get past that
sorry that's the that I could never get
past that and the freaky emo goth did
goblin that we got and amazing
spider-man 2 well not good I was like
well I'm strangely fascinated by this
thing more but but what what about
snowboarding goblin is forgot about that
didn't yeah I remember people say that
it was gonna be like a version of the
Hobgoblin I'm like sir I've met the
Hobgoblin I know you are Doha okay I
think I think I'm dead I'm not gonna
actually mention all the ones I've got
on here cuz some of them like I don't
have all that much to say about I need
to talk about the the four that I I have
lumped together for basically all
committing the same sin okay so I'm
trying to do I want to say what the sin
is or what the movies are first I'll say
but the movies are now hood I'll see if
I can
alright figure out ghostbusters - uh-huh
man in black - uh-huh
Kingsman the Golden Circle The Hangover
Part 2 okay I know a lot of what you're
hating about Ghostbusters - but I'm not
sure if it's alright tell me what's the
come thread let's just make the first
one again even if it requires us to
break everything that had happened by
the end of the previous that's where I
thought you were going with with
hangover - certainly
yeah no it's it is the reset button like
first of all it does kind of what I
alluded to want to talk about Highlander
- which is it is lazy yeah
- just go let's just do the first one
again right is lazy but in addition to
that with these hangover - I actually
have not seen but I've read the synopsis
and I'm like that is literally just
banging over one just set in a different
place so I'll lump it in there anyway
but the other three is they literally
undo what arcs and development there was
by the end of their preceding films in
the case of ghostbusters - by breaking
up and disbanding the Ghostbusters so
they have to convince people that ghosts
are real and come all together right
again men and black - bye even though
his story was completely finished
bringing back Tommy Lee Jones for no
friggin reason and then Kingsman to
which I actually think is the worst of
the three not only bringing back a dead
character spoilers for all these but I
don't care cuz they suck not only do
they bring back a dead character whose
death was a big part of the conclusion
of the previous guys story they cut they
completely kill off one like V major
female supporting character offhandedly
within the first five minutes and barely
any ceremony and though like the one
thing that everyone agreed was bad about
the first Kingsman ie the butt joke at
the very end of it not only did they do
a joke that was basically just as bad
they double down on it and insert it in
the middle of the movie instead of
having to be a gag of a plot point hmm
ah yeah I I was disappointed walking out
of it I've come to load that movie but
all four of these they they literally
snap themselves in half bending over
backwards in order to try and be the
first one again and yeah we've talked to
you about ghostbusters 2 a lot of those
and the problems of unnecessarily
breaking them up and just so that they
can get back together and have the same
conversation with the mayor and the yeah
the other governments left tool let's
just make the same movie again well we
can't make the same movie again cuz they
end it in different places then they
started first time okay we'll set them
back to square one well that is actually
that's not the exact reason but that is
similar to why one of the movies on my
list is Terminator 3 Oh which does do
all what is basically kind of like
repeats a lot of Terminator 2 but for me
the biggest sin is it negates Terminator
2 mmm and again like that was you could
argue that Terminator didn't need a
sequel but James Cameron made a sequel
made it better than the previous one it
wasn't better than the previous one but
it was still very okay well argue that
one some other time but you definitely
like that bad point again ambiguity of
the ending but now we're going to screw
up the ambiguity of the ending by
showing you the next chapter in that
there is a certain fixed thing that the
the fate can be changed and everything
in this whole they just like the any I
thought just felt like was kind of like
a
screw you - what was special about
terminator - but they also came in with
the same thing which was that Arnold
came in he was the hero again he was the
protector from a new version of the
Terminator that's trying to kill John
like the same way it's just a lot of
repetition a lot of the same thing but
also spinning the wheels and like
ruining what I liked about the first
about previous terminators I think the
only reason I didn't put that on my list
is I do I keep forgetting that that
movie exists yeah no I literally forget
yeah forget about that movie oh boy um
so after that another one another side
beloved sci-fi franchise picking up
another sequel to a James Cameron movie
I was gotta say you're gonna bring up
alien 3 aren't you and now this is the
one where I actually think alien 3 is a
solid movie I see that for the first
five minutes that completely so here's a
damper on the whole thing I think it is
a problematic often hated sequel that
could have been fixed very simply by not
making Ripley the main character if you
recast
remake somebody else some other strange
woman falls on this planet there's
prison planet full of men and she brings
the alien with her you tell a completely
separate story you don't handcuff this
entire franchise to one particular
actress who the producers and by then
she was a producer of it wanted it to be
all based on her and she wanted it but
then you don't have to kill off a family
unit that we established in the last one
and this loving sort of like hopeful
ending you're not giving the middle
finger to all of that and you just have
another it's a little bit more of a
rehash of the first one then because
then you've just basically got these
characters trapped in a box with a
monster in the dark but the different
scenery the they're sort of religious
themes that are tried to it be inserted
in there but don't quite land at least
you can play off of that the other thing
a lot of that is David Fincher was his
first directorial feature just lifting
this thing on the shoulders and trying
to come up with something that would
work yeah and that was a script that had
been cheered like five times
well they completely
change the premise of the planet they
were wrong halfway into pre-production
um but see here's the thing like I'm not
gonna disagree oh that's a that's a
that's a bad idea but I would actually
say it's not even necessary to have it
not be Ripley all you have to do it's
the most minor of tweaks to she's
separate but new and she's the only one
objecting cuz her pod is the only one
compromised so we're gonna hit stay on
the ship they live what she fought to
save is still saved right we don't
completely crap all over what I mean you
could still say it ruins the happy
ending because she doesn't get to be and
she doesn't get to have a happy ending
but what but she wasn't fighting for
herself she was fighting specifically
for Newt so honestly it's the killing of
Newt that is for me is the original sin
of alien 3 especially considering I come
consider it completely unnecessary to
the plot there is no reason that she
needs to die in order for the rest of
the story to happen absolutely none and
I just think that's because I was a fan
of the aliens franchise and like the
comics and not like other books
everything like I felt that making it a
Ripley story again made the universe
smaller and just kind of attached to
this because by then like when they
eventually decide to make like Alien
Resurrection like you know eight years
later whatever it was or not even that
much but then it was like well the only
way this story makes sense is if we
clone Ripley and we bring her back to
the light it's like just come up with
some different character like Ripley
didn't create these characters there's
not a symbiotic relationship here like
have some other blood in this and I felt
like they just see here's the thing like
I get it to a certain extent and here's
why because you start cycling in other
characters completely and then the Alien
franchise becomes just another horror
franchise where you where you cycle in
new fodder every time it becomes a
sci-fi equivalent of Nightmare on Elm
Street or Friday the 13th or at least it
risks becoming that so I I feel like I
feel like keeping her around was at
least
partly initially sort of the in the
interest of not becoming like those
kinds of horror franchises where it's
just just drop the monster in with a new
bunch of people to rip into every time I
think the budgetary constraints of the
setting at least would kind of suggest
that it could be a venue for more auteur
horror film makers and not you know
somebody coming up with like a 20 you
know a million dollar budget or
something like that but I mean you'd
think so but I mean the thing is like
look at what has been done with the
alien films that have not included
Ripley well then they have not been any
better right and part of that I would
argue is again studio interference in a
mandate that they have to be pg-13 for
at least alien versus Predator ones and
then the Prometheus and the Covenant
which I actually thought about including
covenant then I realize I hated
Prometheus I didn't I did not see coming
I just seen it have you seen the first
two movies okay so I've seen you've seen
alien and aliens you've seen coming yeah
that I I actually don't hate Prometheus
okay it's got a lot of problems and I I
don't like I get it but I don't hate it
um but I saw the first trailer for
Covenant I'm like no don't care now
well if you liked Prometheus there's no
reason for you to like a covenant oh
okay if I mean that if you didn't like
Prometheus like I did there's also no
reason for you to what see that was the
thing like I there were a lot of flaws
in Prometheus but I liked what it was
doing I liked that it was trying to move
the story away from the confines of the
xenomorph cuz I felt like if you were
gonna try and expand it you need to get
away from that creature because that
does just turn it into a recycling
horror franchise so I I saw potential in
Prometheus I liked it but I really
wanted to see the follow up I wanted to
see what they went after that and they
decided to just I could tell just from
the trailer and everything I've read
bears this out this is how you just
scrap all that and just mess around with
aliens again I'm like and now we don't
what your your voice was in the minority
of the fans because ya wanted another
alien movie so they're like alright well
why
here's here's another alien movie yeah
we'll drop a bomb on the plan that you
could have had for the follow-up to yes
and make sure that that never comes to
fruition yeah I accept that I'm in the
minority of people who actually wanted a
proper follow-up to prometheus
but with what they did they literally
satisfied nobody you probably had a lot
of minority opinions throughout what
apologies if the image just like jumped
around I'm still figuring this camera
out anyways I think you had one more I
do have one more and controversial pic
and I don't want to completely well I
can read the only one with controversial
opinions come on and this is actually
one that I think you and I are kind of
on the same wavelength for this movie
alright but the reason that I have it on
my list and the movie itself is Star
Wars the last Jedi ah yes now the reason
I put this on my list for a very
specific reason I kind of want to just
limit the discussion of the movie to one
particular thing and it's the reason
this is on my list is because it makes
me like the previous movie the force
awakens less I have my we've talked
about this enough that I think I know
why that is but why don't you tell the
people at home okay so credit to Mike
Gillis from the podcast radio versus the
Martians and podcast LaVista baby
because he actually had he articulated
something about the force awakens that I
think is kind of like brilliant and I
was never able to actually say but he
described the force awakens as a remix
of the original Star Wars and I think
that's kind of a great way of like
looking at it because it kind of says it
explains and almost kind of justifies
and excuses why it is
story-wise have a remake of the original
with a lot of the same kind of plot
beats and and seams but a little bit
jazzier you know there's a little bit
like DJ you know skips and everything
like that but that works and you can
excuse that and you can even embrace
that and love it if that's a one-off
experience mmm a remix of the first one
that type of like love letters that is
not where you begin a new saga or a new
the G or the or continuation of this
saga with these new characters because
what the last gen I'd then did was kind
of have to pick up those pieces and say
well this stuff is just a retread of
that so if we don't like that so we're
just gonna ignore him we're gonna just
can't all that or this character is
pointless so we're just gonna kill him
off and we're gonna do all of these
other things and it's just kind of by
approaching the world the way the last
did I did which was to kind of say
everything you liked about the other
movie we're gonna flip it on its head
for sort of the sake of flipping it kind
of like it just made me feel like the
lad the force awakens didn't not that it
didn't matter but it just kind of made
me feel like it was like I liked it for
the wrong reasons
well it's certain it certainly felt like
the last Jedi was telling you that you
liked it for the wrong reasons and
started because you and I are pretty
much on the same page with the last Jedi
which is that we both dislike it but not
for the right and there's not not for
the most frequently quoted reasons on
the internet that people have for just
like yeah this is why I haven't even
done a review of the movie on the Star
Wars podcast that I used to host because
I don't want people just a Ryan hates
the movie well he's one of the people
that try to trash Kelly berry train
until she leaves social media yeah he
must be one of the people who wants to
like a sign a petition to get it like
that like I didn't like that movie but I
hated Star Wars fandom after that movie
and yeah
I didn't want to be associated with the
people who hate that movie for I think
the wrong reasons my problems with the
movie are just very different but one of
them and the the thing that I the sequel
miss of it that bothers me is just I was
like well I really liked the force
awakens but now I don't
and it's because like I was counting on
this movie I was counting on the last to
salvage things about the force awakens
that I knew were problems like the way
the government had been established and
not released up and like the way the
characters were kind of locked into the
same roles that they were in 40 years
earlier yeah and like Luke just looking
like a bitter old version of obi-wan and
the first order being the empire 2.0 and
the resistance being the rebellion 2.0
allows it well it can't be that simple
because that means everything they
fought for in the last trilogy didn't
matter there's gotta be something else
more to this and the last one I said
nope that's exactly what it is and it
was stupid
so we don't care about it I'm like okay
well that's depressing these funny
because you took I'm on board the big
complaint I had before the before the
force awakens even come out on your
podcast
yeah we thought about a long time ago
you were like a sequel kind of ruins
Return of the Jedi for yes so what
that's kinda funny I I am with you
because the for me the the big things
like I part of why I don't like the last
gen I don't think it's the only reason
but part of why I don't like the last
Jedi is as a sequel to The Force awakens
specific mmm-hmm because it does feel
like a very cruel bait-and-switch
sure on fans because for the first
sequel to this franchise in 30 yeah 30
plus years and everything about the
sequel from who's in it to how it's shot
to the lot like send it to remix all of
it says it's Star Wars is you remember
it's a nostalgia trip yes and then the
last thing and then the last Jedi goes
this is not option is for idiots yeah
this is not the Star Wars you remember
and honestly either one of those is fine
but it's not okay to set up your new
trilogy on the basis of one and then
come in with the other right that I feel
is cruel to fans because that is going
here you want this carrot it's not a
carrot it's a truncheon and now we're
gonna beat you in it which is why I like
and unfortunately I think I think they
screwed up that way because I think Rian
Johnson could make a really cool trilogy
completely separated from the Sanya and
doing his own vision with which solution
he's now working on and now I wish they
just had him do that but the things like
with the last shot being as divisive and
as hated by a lot of people it's like I
don't know if that trilogy is gonna have
yeah I don't know either but like if he
was gonna make a Star Wars I wish they
just had him do that and the other thing
is
even seen people defend the last shot on
the basis going it's deconstructionist
and I actually I don't disagree but to
me that's damning because what do you do
when you deconstruct something you
destroy it but that is the nature of
deconstructionist narrative is to pull
the thing apart and dissect it and when
you do that you kill it that's why the
great deconstructionist work on in
ongoing franchises like the like The
Dark Knight Returns like Superman bred
some like Watchmen which was originally
conceived to be all these Charlie
characters it's why all of these are
allegories to existing characters or are
out of continuity takes on them you
can't deconstruct in a story you are
trying to continue moving forward and
that's why the people who love The Dark
Knight and red Sun and watch men in
these movies and under those books sorry
and understand what makes them special
why those people hate the sequels that
were created for Watchmen and the Dark
Knight and Evelyn yes oh man those I
mean yeah those were the ones I got and
for the various various reasons a lot of
times I think these were sequels that
should not have been because the movie
before them did not require a sequel and
and they were probably best left either
open-ended or the opposite just very
finite and throwing in a sequel for the
purposes of making more money and doing
another sequel it was just wrong headed
sometimes they just pass their pilot
like probably like I haven't seen
Incredibles - I think Incredibles -
could get away with that because it's
animated
so I Incredibles 2 is not bad it is
incredibly unnecessary and it was
absolutely not worth the wait it is it
is the exact sequel that I would have
accepted two years after the inquisitors
came out not what is it 14 years later
like no no no 14 years later this is the
best you could come up with no this was
not worth the wait it's not I mean it
does it doesn't ruin the previous one it
doesn't make a lot of the mistakes that
I was expecting it to make but it still
isn't very good
it's not a worthy successor to the
original and I see these gushing reviews
every now that I'm like what movie did
you see and so help me God if the
Incredibles 2 wins for Best Animated
Feature over into the spider-verse
just cuz it's Pixar there better be a
pillow within reach because whenever I
get my hands on first I'm gonna throw
people riot
so I mean while they should have ride it
when brave one but they let that slide
cuz it's pixel Pixar movies are good but
like at this point I kind of have I kind
of have a bone in my craw over how much
of a past that company gets just because
of the brand name so well yeah those are
the other the other sequels that I
mentioned I had problems with just
because they spit on or cropped on
something that was great about the one
before it's actually you know what I
could have put on here I don't feel like
talking about it again cuz it's too soon
I could have talked about wreck-it Ralph
to okay but I've already got a review of
but I don't wanna very there you go so I
think well I think we'll wrap it up
there what do you folks think are some
really bad whoa what do you think about
the ones we talked about I'm sure many
of you will disagree with at least some
of the things we've said oh I'm sure
somebody out there thinks The Godfather
too and Wrath of Khan does hurt to be a
harmless if somebody wants to make that
arguing insincerity I actually want to
hear it but whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's also a whole
bunch of buttons down there and there's
a link to the patreon if you feel like
supporting what I do and there's other
things besides on check them out if you
want if you don't that's okay too
because at the end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings
occasionally with this doofus in tow so
you're right this wasn't as good as the
last time I know until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]